all right guys
bang bang i've got matt here super
excited about this thank you so much for
doing this sir
you're welcome thank you for having me
it's an honor for sure
uh let's just jump right into uh your
background um
and uh how you kind of first came across
crypto but what did you do
before uh before you had ever heard
about bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
yeah sure um so i've been a reporter at
bloomberg news since 2004.
uh that's when i moved to new york city
from california
uh got a job there eventually kind of
started reporting about market structure
issues um and like in the the
derivatives world and the bond market
and that's like how things work or don't
work um
when the financial crisis happened the
swaps market had a big role to play
there
it was unregulated it was crazy wild
west
so i jumped into that and followed the
dodd-frank law
through congress and then through when
the cftc
started putting all those new
regulations into place
uh i also was following the the fixed
income market like treasuries trading
uh one of the biggest markets in the
world which is you know i don't know if
a lot of your readers know
listeners know but it's basically
unregulated it's just kind of another
wild west it's just the you know
sovereign debt of the united states
and so i had heard about bitcoin i think
around 2013 or 14
and dismissed it i didn't get it um i
think
you know i it just didn't make sense to
me
and and i regret that you know um but
when in about 2015 or so i understood
what made bitcoin possible with
blockchain technology i quickly realized
that
that had the potential to change
everything that i wrote about
so i went to my editor and i said hey
you know i want to make blockchain a
part of my beat
and he's like cool what's blockchain and
so
you know there was a nothing uh i was
one of the first people at bloomberg to
get in on that
and so i started following it and
it really is like for me it's been where
um
finance and blockchain or distributed
ledger meet
so one of the first stories i did was
about um
blythe masters who was a big person at
jp morgan she helped invent the credit
default swap
and then went to the ceo of digital
asset
holdings then the next year the dow came
around and i started getting
you know more interested in ethereum and
continued to write about how crypto
and blockchain could change finance and
um
then i didn't write about the doubt as
it was happening
um but uh later that year my editor came
to me and said hey we're doing a heist
issue for the magazine do you know of
any good heists and i said oh yeah the
dow
you know this would be this is going to
be a story for you
and so i got to dig into that um
i got to know everybody uh a lot of the
people anyway um
involved and so i did that story you had
the most fun i'd ever had
reporting and writing and i was able to
luckily
take that magazine story and say all
right this is a really dramatic
episode in this history early history of
ethereum what if i strung this out over
a book
and around this story told people about
vitalik and told people about joe lubin
and gavin wood and you know all the guys
that slack it who
created the dao and so that was the idea
and
luckily i got to you know i got somebody
to go along with me
and uh here we are with the book um
that's coming out here in the next week
or so
absolutely so that book is called out of
the ether and i've had the pleasure of
reading some of it beforehand uh and
what's really
fascinating to me is uh you kind of
almost
uh go back and forth between this like
macro view
of um you know ethereum the community
kind of some of the potential uh and
then this one event right
where you're able to kind of go deep on
the dow itself talk through a little bit
about just like
the process of um you know kind of
understanding
what happened uh and the process of
tracking some of these people down
and kind of their uh openness and
willingness to talk to you versus maybe
some that didn't like just what was the
process of getting the information to
write the book
yeah that's a that's a great question um
and i liked i like structuring that way
it's
you'd like to have some tension
throughout the whole book so you want to
keep reading and figure out
like am i going to find this person or
people
um so as i said i i knew a lot um
so first of all there was there's
several different groups of hackers
like there was the bad guy who attacked
the dow on friday
june 17th 2016. stole 55 million dollars
over the course of that day
um that kind of led to a group of good
guy hackers who started calling
themselves the robin hood group they got
together
and started like figure trying to figure
out hey can we figure out who this
person
is um can we figure out how they did it
and we need to do something here to you
know basically save the rest of the
money in the dow
because there was still you know around
200 million dollars of ether in the dow
so i got to know those guys well in 2017
when i wrote the magazine story
and um through that reporting i kept
hearing whispers of like
yeah we think the person who attacked
the dow was there in switzerland
but they would never tell me more than
that they were um
it was pretty much not it was about
it was like rumor level material right
so these guys didn't want to give me a
name
um but that's what i always kept hearing
so when it came time to report the book
i went back and i dug in on that and um
i was able to to
get some names and i connected with
people
who i didn't connect with in 2017 so my
sources were better
also the blockchain forensics that you
could do in 2019 when i was writing and
recording the book
are much better than they were back in
2016
when people were looking into who might
have attacked the dow
so um all those things came together to
give me a much better chance of finding
somebody and finding leads the second
and really important thing here is
that friday attack was not the only
attack on the dow there was a second one
and there were in fact many other little
ones but the second one was on tuesday
so it was four days later and it's the
second biggest attack and it ended up
stealing about three and a half million
dollars with an ether
this is the attack that like robin and
group guys were all ready to go
but they didn't know if they were gonna
be like breaking the law if they
hacked the dow and stole all the rest of
the ether to you know protect it like
they didn't know if people would believe
them that they were going to give it
back so
they were like on the fence but then on
tuesday the second attack
happens and they're like okay screw it
we've got to go and get
the rest of the ether in there or else
it's gonna get stolen again
so um this second attack
in my opinion was a copycat uh it was a
lot sloppier than the friday attack
and they left some trails and i was able
to pick up on those trails
and eventually connect um that attack to
um a withdrawal at poloniex
and i was luckily i had a source who was
able to tell me
which account that was at polo that made
the bitcoin withdrawals that
if you follow the blockchain went to
fund that second
attack on tuesday got it and so when you
get that kind of person identified uh
what do you do in terms of is that just
the end of the trail or were you able to
do anything with that information
no um so i i had
in the book there's two examples of this
the first is these people in switzerland
and so that's why i originally thought
was were responsible so
what you do as a reporter now i've got a
name
i get in touch with that person and say
hey i'm writing a book about
the early history of ethereum i'd love
to come talk to you
i'm going to be in zurich you know let's
meet up
and so um that's what i did in
switzerland and i sat down with this man
who i chronicled this in an early part
of the book
and we had this long discussion about
the dao
and then it turned out afterwards i
learned that he had nothing to do with
it because the information i had been
given was wrong
and that goes back to how the blockchain
forensics in 2016 were much less
developed than in 2019
so some sources who were helping me now
had a much better picture in 2019 and
they said oh crap
that guy and zordik he's wrong he's not
the right guy
um so but we do think here is a guy
in tokyo and you should go talk to him
so on the second lead i did the same
thing
i got in touch with this person and i
said hey i'm writing a book
uh you were active in ethereum in japan
and i'd love to come talk to you
i'm gonna be in tokyo because you have
to sit down with these people
uh if you call them up on the phone and
start asking them if they attack the dow
they're gonna hang up on you so the
trick is to just kind of
you know i you don't lie or anything but
you just say hey i'd like to talk to you
about your experiences in this community
and so that's what i did in both cases
um
in the case of the guy in tokyo you know
i think he is
he is involved in that attack his
account was used
and you know your listeners can check
out the book where i get into a lot more
detail about this
where he says in a nutshell
other people had access to his polo
account and he thinks that they might
have been able
to pull off this second attack and i
left it at that
because that's all i could do as a
reporter you know i don't have a
subpoena i'm not the fbi
and i just want to give it straight to
people and they can make up their own
mind about it
yeah and what's so interesting about
this is obviously if these were kind of
uh
traditional finance crimes right in
terms of just with a bank or whatever
these people would be caught immediately
arrested and
be pretty open and shut do you feel like
there was um kind of different handling
whether it was by
uh the media by law enforcement or maybe
even the community given that
uh this all happened in kind of a wild
west time
for crypto yeah that's a great point um
you know i know people for a fact went
to the fbi
and talked to different agents the
justice department was involved
um who would you know they're the
prosecutor so if the fbi wants to bring
a case the
doj would prosecute it i spoke to a
former doj prosecutor
the the feeling is that there was there
were definitely people in the united
states who were harmed
by the dow theft that but that
jurisdiction would have been a nightmare
because it was global
and it was it was a really um from a law
enforcement point of view
a really tough case to to first of all
explain
to people um and then to try it you know
because let's not forget through the
actions of the ethereum community
they did the hard fork and everybody got
their money back you know
everybody who had money stolen from the
dow got it back
not only that they got ethereum classic
on top of it so
if you have money and a doubt at the end
of the day in like late 2016
you were in a better financial position
than you were earlier
in the year there so
and then lastly regulators and
law enforcement i think we're um just
starting to get
into how to to go after people in this
world in 2016.
um if you know about like russell brick
and
um you know silk road you know that
if you remember the amazing part of that
story was that the fbi had to catch him
with his laptop open right and then they
were able to link him
and his keys to all the stuff that he'd
been doing on the bitcoin network with
silk road so
it's like it's that like takes
red-handed to a whole new level
and here you know you have this like
global you know
we still don't know who the people are
they cover their tracks really well
for the big friday attack and so
you know i think if it happened today i
think it'd be a much different response
but back then like you said
it was a wild west and and regulators
and law enforcement were only
really starting to understand what they
needed to do to go after people like
that
yeah and talk maybe a little bit about
kind of you're talking to many of these
people
after this has all happened right and so
they're they're kind of
able to live through it think about okay
here was the situation
uh and really formulate opinions in
hindsight
what were most of these people's
thoughts on this was this just oh yeah
that was the dow hack and like no big
deal because we basically found a
solution
um or were the people still upset
and worried about it and kind of felt
like uh it had been
unaddressed um and maybe that was the
wrong way to handle it
yeah i mean it's a mix right you don't
have like one community in this
in this space as you well know um there
are definitely people who
um want to just leave it in the past you
know that they live through it and don't
want to really revisit it
other people when i talk to them still
get like visibly excited like this is
one of the most amazing things that
they'd ever been through and
you just have to start asking about it
and they just like their face lights up
and they start speaking louder and
cussing more and you know um
so i think you know and then i think uh
a lot of people feel like you know this
person or people who did this
you know they're not they're like they
weren't
nice they were malicious you know they
wanted to steal
from this community i guess i've heard
this from several people that
you know they could have just like given
the money back and said hey i approved a
point
you know or something like that they
didn't want to do that and so i think
in some ways there's a lot of hard
feelings still about that and
um and i think like
some of the people who helped me in 2019
um did so i think because they
um wanted to know what more about this
you know they were they were
um they sort of liked it that i was
willing to
dig into this again and go not only just
like
if you give me a name i'm gonna go to
switzerland or i'm gonna go to japan
and i'm gonna talk to this person and
i'm gonna try to figure it out you know
that's that's a reporter's job
and so i think that they appreciated
that i was willing to
um you know do that
and obviously uh ethereum you mentioned
earlier has
this like potential impact on market
structure in the legacy finance world
just talk through uh you're writing a
book
about it right and during that process
you obviously learn more and more and
you learn who the players are and kind
of
almost get this like crash course if you
will uh
on the technology on the people on
specific events
after all that like how do you think
about uh the potential impact on market
structure is this something where
you're kind of more convinced that's
gonna happen maybe less convinced
like just where do you kind of come out
on uh the legacy financial world and
and the blockchain world intersecting
yeah i think i'm only getting more
convinced that it's going to lead to
something and
it has already led to something um
you know and what it does as we're
seeing there's
there's some cycles going on here the
ico boom
in 2017 was crazy for for the asset
prices that went up so high
but what that proved to people was
here's a new way to
raise capital for your project you don't
need a bank you don't need a vc
you can go directly to users and ask
them to invest
well there's a ton of scams that's a
brand new
funding model which is fantastic we're
in the d5 craze right now which
is is another kind of building block
it's about loaning
and collateralizing and earning interest
and
you know those are all like mainstays of
finance and yet
they're being done in a permissionless
peer-to-peer environment
and so that's you know two years three
years later
so i think we're seeing that like these
building blocks are being put in place
and they're being battle tested
and there have been mistakes like the
dow and like yam
and other things um but when the dust
settles
there is now a new component to this
entire ecosystem that
is only going to get built upon so
that's what i find
fascinating and i think
you're seeing more and more mainstream
adoption you're seeing places like
reddit
you know come to ethereum um you're
seeing
uh the financial world um come to
ethereum
and i think just the smart contract
construct that vitalik created is
something that once you get it
is really appealing to a lot of
different people in a lot of different
industries
yeah and it feels like a lot of this has
been driven by
uh kind of financial market outsiders
right so that it
tends to be younger uh people they tend
to
much more technical than kind of finance
uh understanding
um is that still
persistent today like you spent a lot of
your time looking at the traditional
financial markets a lot of
uh players and employees at these large
banks or large financial services
companies what's their kind of awareness
of all this happening
is there interest like what's the kind
of incumbent view of what's happening
uh right now i i think
it varies by bank and it varies by
institution for sure
on wall street you know you've got jp
morgan is probably
you know going the furthest here with um
you know they were in it from the
beginning or very close to the beginning
with ethereum
uh they just sold quorum to consensus um
they're still working on jpm coin they
still have this inner
bank network that is you know an
alternative
uh corresponding banking system that
uses digital currency
um you've got companies like fidelity
with abby johnson
who you know she's mining bitcoin and
they're going all in
um i was told that the view of
digital currencies and crypto at
fidelity is like a 20-year game
you know that's how they're seeing this
um
then you got other banks and other
financial institutions that
still are writing it off and don't think
it's gonna ever amount to anything
i think um what's being built is an
alternative system
i don't think that we're talking about a
replacement here but
it's it's giving people um who want
an alternative to the traditional
financial system or
talk about the in the world wide web in
web 3.0 you know
an alternative to um having your data
mined and sold and your searches being
you know following you for
months when you go about your business
on the web
so you know i think that that's what's
that's what's happening
and it's gonna take something big
for um you know traditional finance to
to catch up i think and that and i i
don't think that's out of the ordinary i
think that's what often happens that
secondary movers are often more powerful
than primary movers
yeah and it also feels like there's a
mismatch or an
outgunning of resources right in terms
of uh
that the big banks can just throw so
much money and resources
uh some will argue that's a good thing
actually somebody even argued that's a
bad thing right because they kind of
just trip over their own feet
so talk a little bit you know is it an a
competition right
is this kind of the decentralized
permissionless
uh kind of challenger type uh ecosystem
up against these big banks or do you
think this ends up being much more
collaborative over time
i think it will um
i think both i think you know um i think
you've seen a bit of a brain drain from
wall street a lot of people have left
to go to crypto you've certainly seen a
lot of traders
leave to just trade the assets because
there's so much volatility and so much
opportunity to make money
you're not seeing that really in the
financial markets right now the
traditional ones
anyway and um
but you've got firms like ernst young
their head of blockchain
is 100 on building on the public
ethereum blockchain like that's what
they're telling their clients you should
be doing
um you think you know they think it's
safer than like private chains or
distributed ledgers
and he thinks that you know this is the
way it's all going
so again i think it's gonna you're gonna
have
separate things that grow up side by
side and then maybe there'll be some
merging and whatnot but
um i don't think bitcoin is gonna
replace the dollar
you know as the world reserve currency
um
i think that much more likely that the
us is going to issue
digital dollars and that's going to i
mean imagine what that does now
to the ecosystem where a stable coin
isn't necessary any longer
so you know i that that's the way i see
it um
and you know i don't think jp morgan is
doing what it's doing because it's
afraid it's gonna
have its lunch eaten you know by these
people i think that they see
a real business opportunity a way to
save money and a way to make money
that's that's all
that wall street cares about and when
you when they see that and especially
when somebody proves it out
for them then everybody else is going to
jump right in there and do the same
thing
yeah it's it's very very interesting to
see um
there's multiple people in the in kind
of legacy financial world who
they themselves personally are a little
bit older right there's been around a
long time
um and they kind of have one view and
then now their kids are actually
becoming old enough to
start to enter the world themselves so
we've seen this in the gold community
we've seen this through some
uh of the you know very prominent
bankers where basically their kids are
into the crypto stuff and they may not
be and so
uh it almost is uh you know funny to
watch
just the the demographic shift or the
generational difference
uh between um ray diallo who just said
that recently that
he was trying to get his son to buy gold
and his son's like no i'm buying bitcoin
there's a bunch of them so my
understanding i think is uh jamie dimon
ray dalio
uh peter schiff like there's a bunch of
these people who
uh just naturally right if you take kind
of digitally native
younger people and you say hey uh where
are you going to invest
you know i joke all the time about like
this like millennial portfolio that we
all
you know kind of turn into a meme so
it's like you have tesla you've got
bitcoin
you know you're doing it on robin hood
whatever uh but like as the wealth shift
happens like that
kind of becomes a reality right if
that's people's preference like
i don't know if that ever gets reversed
so and anything in terms of as you were
writing the book that kind of
struck you in terms of the way that the
people you were interviewing and
speaking with
invested that seem different than maybe
the the sources you have that come from
more traditional wall street backgrounds
yeah um i i think
um what i love about crypto is that and
and
ethereum especially i think there's a
real streak of idealism
you know they a lot of these guys truly
believe that they're changing the world
and and um i think that appeals to me as
a reporter because every reporter has to
have
a bit of idealism in them to do this job
because you have to think that you're
gonna you know be changing the world or
helping people by what you're doing
and then we often turn very cynical
because it's i think it's a mechanism to
kind of hide that idealism
but i have that and i recognized it in a
lot of the people
um that i spoke to like in the
co-founders group that created ethereum
and in the broader world um
about you know they're in it to try to
make
not everybody i don't want to say that
but there is a good significant chunk of
people who really do
want to make the better of the world
better and you don't find that in
finance
um you don't you know go to goldman
sachs to make the world better
um and so that that's that's a big
difference
and i think uh you know it can lead to
naivety
um but i also think that the one of the
strongest things
ethereum has going for it is the
community it's built
up around the developers and supporters
and people
who are all necessary to make this
ecosystem vibrant
and i think if you talk about
somebody coming in another blockchain
coming in and displacing ethereum
you've got to get around the really real
issue that all of those developers and
people in the community have spent years
of their lives dedicated to it and it's
a
you know it's something that they truly
believe in so i find that
really interesting what was the biggest
surprise for you
as you wrote the book in terms of maybe
something you didn't expect or that you
found out and it was surprising
uh um there was a lot
i i think getting to know vitalik
buterin was a lot of fun i mean i
wouldn't say i know him well but i spent
a good amount of time with him
he shared personal emails with me um
his dad shared with me this amazing
document called the encyclopedia of
bunnies that he wrote when he was seven
years old
like 20 page word document all about
rabbits and bunnies and how fast they
are and how many man
and girl bunnies are there and it's just
like there's this window into his mind
as a seven-year-old
we all know he's brilliant but like he's
also really whimsical and funny
and he's incredibly well-rounded
i interviewed a bunch of his high school
teachers
and you know he was he was reading the
iliad in
in latin you know and starting greek and
and doing stuff that like you know most
high school students never dream of
and and yet you know so i i hope
readers agree that like i was able to i
think get a nice rounded portrait of him
as a human being rather than
as this kind of programming whiz kid who
created ethereum when he was 19.
and i think quickly the other thing that
surprised me
was how ethereum succeeded almost in
spite of itself because the management
that
vitalik had around him from the very
beginning was just
a [ __ ] show you know like people there
there were
egos and clashes from the very beginning
um six months into the project people
were fired there was some reshuffling
then a few months later people were also
let go
they tried to bring in a professional
board of directors and an executive
director
who were at each other's throats within
you know days
uh the board was fired and yet
through all of that like people kept
building you know and the idea was there
and it was sound and it was
fleshed out enough where i guess they
could just kind of block out that noise
and keep going and um you know
eventually release ethereum so
i mean if you if you'd seen this
management track record of any other
company you would just be like how in
the hell
did you actually create a product and
deliver it you know
i love that um in in terms of uh what we
spend most of our time talking today is
kind of the new world
uh you also though as a as a reporter i
spent a lot of time writing about kind
of the old world or
the the legacy world uh we have just
lived through
some of the the most incredible market
volatility and kind of market gyrations
um that many people have lived through
uh
talk just your general sense of like
what's happened
uh from a macro environment standpoint
kind of how we've seen this play out
whether it's you know repo market type
stuff all the way through to uh stuff
that we've seen
uh in response to the federal reserve
actions over the last couple of months
yeah it's it's been wild um and i think
the first thing that comes to mind is
you know we're we are living through
a zero rate interest rate environment
for far longer than it has ever been
tried before and
it's it's so we're in uncharted
territory there and i think
you're seeing the knock-on effect um you
know
in all sorts of markets in like you know
you've got high-yield bonds that are
trading
sort of now where corporate bonds used
to trade and corporate bonds are like
where you might be
used to get a certificate of deposit you
know kind of
return um everybody's just been pouring
everything they have
into the stock market because i think
they feel like that's the only place
that's that's moving um
you've seen things like knit oil
crashing negative for the first time um
which you know is a possibility it's
just that i think nobody ever thought
it would happen and then it happened in
in an afternoon and
everybody was just you know it was sort
of like another thing to be dumbfounded
about
um we saw some crazy moves in the
treasury market in march
uh so to me it just feels like it's
really really fragile right now
and and there's
my sense and i don't really have much to
go on is just the liquidity in all these
different markets is
is about this deep you know and it can
disappear at any moment
and people really don't know what to do
with their money
um you know you're you can't
earn a safe return in almost anything
right now so
i i think i think this had made a giant
mistake
years ago when it didn't just rip the
bandit off and start raising rates
it would have to me shown that they were
confident in the economy
you know that that we can raise rates
you know
in a methodical way back to three four
five percent
because we think you know that would
have said in the market we think the
u.s economy can withstand that they
never did
and they never did they never did and
then i think it became too late
and so i i feel like you know
from a late i mean i don't know much
more than you even though i
work at bloomberg you know it just feels
like
the the central monetary policy went off
the rails a long time ago and nobody
had the forethought to just put it back
on track
matt you sound like a bitcoiner saying
all that
i mean i i couldn't agree with you more
right it just feels like
uh we're almost addicted to the
manipulation
right so uh how you get off now
you know is uh up for debate but i don't
think that it's another mystery right
like how can the fed be or the treasury
be printing so much money and inflation
just doesn't budge it's um i think
like uncharted territory i that doesn't
make much sense to me i don't think it
makes a lot of sense to many people
so the only thing that
there is to do is to pour your money
into the stock market
and that's what we've seen i mean the
market where it is right now was the
general unemployment level and the fact
that people are not really going out in
this country still
is to me shocking like i cannot believe
we we're up
and back above the all-time high we
reached in march
um that that's just that that's a big
red flag
yeah it is uh it is quite shocking and
it sounds like you're kind of of the
belief that a lot of this is driven by
that market intervention
and we kind of don't know where we would
be if we didn't have the intervention
uh but we kind of know where where we've
gotten with it right it's kind of this
weird thing of
i think a lot of people are kind of
looking at it saying like this probably
isn't a good thing just given where we
are and kind of the inflated asset
prices given that the market reality or
economic reality
but on the same you know side like we
don't know where we would have been if
there hadn't been the intervention right
and so it's kind of hard to judge right
decision or wrong decision
uh because you're just missing data
almost yeah
absolutely and i mean it's summed up
perfectly in the cliche of you know
don't fight the fed
uh that is becoming truer and truer than
it ever has been that is for sure
um help me understand uh in terms of
where we go from here so uh you are a a
reporter at bloomberg
uh you kind of covered the the
traditional markets and then you
had what i'll call kind of uh an early
entry into
uh bitcoin ethereum blockchain uh but as
that becomes
bigger and bigger story and finance do
you see
your role kind of taking on just more
and more of the blockchain do you kind
of continue to balance it
and and maybe not specifically just you
but just the media in general
um kind of where they find the balance
between like this new world and the
existing world how do you think through
that
i think yeah for myself first of all um
i'm definitely going to continue doing
what i'm doing because
i think um you know the two worlds are
coming together
more and more and i don't see many signs
of that stopping
uh so that that's gonna be my role at
bloomberg
um i think
i think that's other traditional media
um that i'm i'm thinking of
you know i think i've pulled back a
little bit from covering
um the markets and i or or
the technology and i think they might
come to regret that because i think
there will be a point here
um where there is
more of a coming together and and things
um you know maybe it's web 3.0
that is is starting to be more widely
available
maybe it's um you know i i don't really
know to be honest but
i funny story that you're asking about
like writing the book when i first got
my contract
um it was serious bear market you know
think nothing was happening
the um the and i wondered i was like god
okay
i wonder if ethereum is gonna survive
you know this is like early 2019
and i'm like the only thing that cheered
me up was like okay this
this period i want to write about
happened it is history so that's fine
you know
let's write about it and no matter what
happens with ethereum
it's a period worth writing about and a
story worth telling
and then you know as 2019 progressed and
then
you know everything started turning up
and and
things seemed a lot more positive and
now we're i think in this
secondary upcycle here with d5 that we
saw back with the ico
boom so i i feel better about that but
um you know it is a boom and bust cycle
and i think
a lot of financial innovation goes
through this um
so you know like the credit default swap
market that was great for people at the
beginning
because you don't have a way to short
bonds you know
like that's that's you can't really
hedge your risk in a bond trade
so that was fantastic for people and
then of course it went completely off
the rails and
and we saw what happened with you know
how
a bunch of cds could be turned into a
cdo and all of that
it almost brought down the global
financial system so
i i think there's going to be a boom and
bust and i think the traditional media
need to pay attention to it and i hope
they do if it feels like
uh you're right in that um
based on each publication some are
doubling down and some are pulling back
and i tend to obviously agree with you
that uh those that are doubling down and
still
kind of covering it will uh will reap
the rewards uh
you know what when the those worlds
merge and then and the line gets grayer
if you will right
yeah yeah i think so i know
you've been writing or talking about
nfts lately and
that's another interesting issue here um
because
you know people like to laugh about
crypto kitties from a couple years ago
but what what they really did was prove
that a digital atom could be scarce
and that's the only way you do that is
with blockchain and
so you know you think about what napster
did to the music industry
you know my once i upload metallica cd i
can send that to a million people
and that it's not scarce but if you
link a digital good to a blockchain now
you can prove that it's a one of a
hundred
set and so people like in the in the
high fashion world like gucci and prada
they want to explore this technology to
have their customers be able to verify
that now this is really a prada bag
you know i didn't buy this on the street
in new york city it is worth twenty
thousand dollars
and so you've got that aspect to it and
then like digital art and digital
commerce um
being scarce i think is that's kind of
this
it's these unknowns that are so
fascinating that what what develops from
you know something that italic and other
people did
five four five years ago here we are now
that's what
i find really intellectually stimulating
is just the way
that new people coming into it like take
the technology and do what they want
with it and now we've got a whole new
kind of asset class or a whole new
possibility
yeah to me it's uh if you can
get the provable scarcity rather this
digital scarcity
uh which it seems like uh you know we've
got now
uh you're going to recreate everything
that's scarce in the physical world
uh in some form or fashion is naturally
going to migrate to this digital
uh world and it really comes down to
one's a story and one's
just math or provable right because the
story of like that you know that
high-end bag or
a piece of gold or a piece of art uh
we have to trust the story right and
sure those people who try to do things
around authenticate uh authenticity
and and really making sure as best they
can
but there's nothing like being able to
just prove the scarcity
um and allow anyone to verify and i tend
to think that that is a
kind of a mental paradigm shift if you
will but uh
when when people kind of switch over and
say oh wow this is the innovation
uh then it becomes pretty amazing to
kind of see what you know i personally
think is going to happen over the coming
years
yeah it's absolutely a kind of a light
bulb moment for people they need to have
that
and then i think all new um vista opens
up for what is possible
for sure uh before we uh we go to wrap
up i always ask
the same two questions to everyone and
you'll get to ask me one to finish
the first is just what is the most
important book that you've ever read
uh and for you you can't cheat and say
your own so you've got to pick another
book but what's the most important book
that you've ever read
wow that is a good question
i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm a huge fiction
guy and i think
uh i'm gonna say uh it was booked by don
dele little
called um uh oh jesus you're making me
space on the name
uh what's it about
uh it's it's about an airborne toxic
event
and uh it's uh it's it's a wonderful
novel it just kind of
opened up my eyes about what can be done
with writing and how good he is
so i can't believe i can't remember the
name right now um
we'll find it at some point what uh did
you feel at any point that when you were
writing the
um ethereum book that you were writing
fiction almost
it felt like that i mean honestly like
some of the details in there
and it's almost beyond like science
fiction
you know like you wouldn't necessarily
believe that this is like if
it's just it's wacky once you get into
the details of
like the hard fork and ethereum classic
and all that stuff it just it's just
it really was um i felt incredibly lucky
to
have that this story before me where i
got to stick to the facts but it just
seemed
just like insane that's awesome
the book doesn't happen to be a book
called white noise does it
thank you yeah that's it that's that's
my expert google skills real quick there
second question is uh somewhat fiction
related which is aliens
uh believer or non-believer in aliens
my dad uh was a rocket scientist for jpl
for his entire career he designed the
propulsion system for voyager 1 and 2
which is the only man-made object that's
ever gone out of the solar system
so i'm definitely a believer in aliens i
think
if you look at the the math number we
don't even i mean
what do we know about the universe it's
nothing so yeah
there's just no way that we're alone
that is incredible what i mean what was
the dinner table conversation when your
father's doing that
on a daily basis it wasn't so much
dinner but like he would give me rides
to school in the morning and he'd have
this like threaded hose pipe
you know on the bottom like an on the
car seat and i'd be like playing with it
and you know that was like part of his
work of like designing you know this
amazing
propulsion system that was going to send
this thing you know
all the way out to the end of the solar
system
so yeah it was crazy that that's insane
um all right you could ask me one
question to uh to wrap this up what uh
what one question do you have for me
okay there's a hot dog a sandwich
ooh that's a really good question is a
hot dog a sandwich
uh i'm gonna go with no because the
bread's connected
all right so what what do you think i
agree
i think i think it's i think it's
totally different so
you should see online man the people go
for hours on this one
oh really uh so i think i've told the
story before the podcast but you'll find
it's funny
uh my wife uh who's working at fortune
uh
comes from bulgaria when she's like
eight nine years old moves to atlanta
and you know bulgaria has basically
eastern european food right so kind of
just your classic
uh diet and she gets here uh she told me
a story that she goes to school
and one of the first days she's there
they go to the cafeteria and
uh they give her a corn dog and her
first reaction was like what the
hell are they doing with a uh uh hot dog
on a stick with bread around it
right and and you just think like from
an american's perspective like oh yeah
that is kind of weird i guess if you've
never seen that before
so you know a hot dog isn't nearly as
weird but definitely the corn dog i
always think of that story as just like
what are the other things that people
who come to america are just like
she ever had peanut butter and jelly i
don't know if she had ever had one
before
that was one when i was i was traveling
traveling through um
rural uh poland once and met some people
on a train
and my wife and i we had peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches and they looked at
us like we were absolutely insane
and we said no try it and they like they
took it and they took like the tiniest
little bite you've ever seen
in your lives and what they just they
had never seen it before so they're just
scared and they thought it sounded
disgusting and just didn't understand it
and i was trying to tell them like no
like this is like what american kids
grow up eating
it's pb j man that that is so that
mcdonald's i think are like the staples
in every american household now
yeah listen matt thank you so much for
doing this where can people find you on
the internet
and and also find the book yeah you
search my name and bloomberg news all
come up
um i'm on twitter just at matt
mattlacing
the book is out of the ether you can
find it at amazon or
wiley my publisher and uh yeah i'm all
over
the interwebs listen my friend you did a
a fantastic job with the book and i
think people really going to enjoy this
so
highly recommend everyone to go check
out that book and i'll have to do this
again in the future
awesome thank you